mark using your method during the
casting process how does the director
know they're getting the best actor for
the role
okay there's a there's it's a good
question the um
it's going to sound like a strange
answer the first thing is
because you said the best actor for the
role
i would say don't focus on the best
actor for the role
focus on the best character in other
words
i i'll tell you how the method my
technique works when i have an actor
come in and audition
and they'll audition and they're
auditioning with somebody who's reading
with them and it's maybe they have a
scene or
whatever let's assume they just have one
scene it's a three-page scene they're
going to read that scene with a reader
it's a very typical
audition and usually what happens in the
casting process is the director
then once they hear the actor read if
they're at all interested in them
they'll
give them some direction on how to do it
differently
i'm looking at the character differently
than that i think she's more playful i
think she's more serious i think she's
you know more stern she you know
whatever in other words
directors will almost always give a lot
of results
and that's okay that's sort of the
casting process the actor is there to
give
results quickly you know i need more
anger in this scene or whatever
and then they will have the actor do it
again okay
and now they're judging the actor on the
actor's ability to adjust to this
kind of this new direction i don't do
that
i'll have the actor come in the actor
will read as soon as the actor has
finished reading the scene
i will immediately start start talking
to the character and i will start
interrogating the character
now something really bizarre someday
maybe you'll see this karen happens
when the actor is not expecting this
because usually they're not
for a moment and it's a brief moment a
couple of seconds you'll see
this sort of flashes in their eyes like
what's happening
he's talking to the character i'll start
asking the question characters
and usually the character i'll say to
the characters she just read the scene
and i'll just say well that didn't go
very well did it and let's say her name
is
sophia i said sophia that didn't go very
well either yeah i mean your mother's
really not
listening is she and you can see the
actor going through this
moment quick moment of adjustment like
what is going on
and then usually right after that you
see this another little flash and
wham they'll go right back into the
character because this is where the
actor wants to be
the actor really doesn't want more
direction
the actor really doesn't want that's not
what i was looking for
the actor doesn't want to hear any of
that the actor really wants
to be the character so i start talking
to the character and start
interrogating the character and i'll
tell her sophia this isn't going very
well did you die your mother didn't do
that and i'll start asking her questions
and interrogating her and then say okay
let's let's
sophia i'm going to give you a chance
let's try this again which means
it's the second reading of the scene
there's been no direction
whatsoever there's only been
interrogation and she'll do the scene
again
and the scene will change now the scene
doesn't change
after the interrogation because what
i've done is i've moved her internally
or emotionally
if this she if she gives the exact same
performance i'm going
can't use her this actor is not shifting
she's not adjusting at all i didn't ask
her to adjust but she's not adjusting
internally
but that rarely happens getting back to
the casting thing
let's say i have 10 actresses coming to
read for this character sofia
i'm not looking for the best actress i'm
looking for the best sofia
and there's a sofia that exists inside
every single one of them and i want to
meet
that the sophia i want to meet that
character that
is lurking inside each one of them and i
will base my judgment on what i
witness and experience and in in
conversation with
in the interrogation so it goes beyond
the scene because beyond the reading
if i have 12 actors actresses leaving
for sophia
chances are they're 12 good actresses
then how do you make a decision
so let's take an example you know sophia
will her character type is
she's vulnerable she's insecure but
maybe she masks it with a certain
outward confidence so you know that
that's who sophia is so you're trying to
come
see who each actor sort of is as sophia
pull it out
yeah and if one of them maybe is a
better actor maybe they can cry on cue
great but if you don't see maybe that
insecurity or that vulnerability then
you know that's not the real
yeah if you say insecurity and
vulnerability that's masked
and i could say to sofia if you had read
sophia and i could i could say to
sophia this is your mother right your
mother just thinks you're a little girl
aren't you you know
what she never never is never going to
let you grow up when is she going to
start treating you
like an adult now all i'm doing is
building insecurity
vulnerability and i can build that in
about 30 seconds that she's feeling
really weak and vulnerable instead of in
front of her let's say yep but don't
sophia don't let her see it don't let
her see it
be it you can be big short now i'm
building up the mask
everything you just said i'm building up
the map i said don't let her see it let
don't let her say let's go again now
she'll go again and you'll get a totally
different performance
the thing was was she able to
incorporate everything she just went
through
and how does it affect her when i see
her go back to do the scene again
that's that's the real test
do you understand and so it's not acting
there's gonna be i've gone beyond acting
now
i've gone way beyond it and if the
actress gives me the same performance
again i go oh she's got it locked in
she's got you know she's got a plan and
she can't seem to move and actually in
that way of directing her in the casting
process i haven't asked her to do
anything
i haven't asked her to change her
performance at all none
but she's not intuitively moving to this
other level
yeah if i do the interrogation and she
and she's not which means she hasn't
really allowed it in she sort of
answered the question and then when i
said do it again she
she goes the actor takes over i don't
want the actor to take over i want her
to release herself to a process
you